T VOLODYMYR YO
ZELENSKYY IS SPEEBINOUT  T OHIT
INGTON"THE
DAMAGING TE  STATES.  TO HIS CON
WAS BA REFLECT HIE THAT HIS
GGSUPPORTER DIDN'T CONTAS THAT N
FROM THEIR COUNTRY, THAT
AFFECTED UKRAINE'S NATIONAL , L
LEAKS THAT AR TO
POTENTIALLN OFFICIS
E THEY CLAIM THAT THE --
THAT UKRAINIANICIALS
TOLD NOT TO ATTACK RSI THEY  WA
thUA, TALKED OUT OF .N WITH
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS HERE IN
UE, SO IT'S NOT HE
LEAKS WHATAS WHAIRETY OF T
FALSE, WHAWATHE LEAKS THAT WERAN
BUE REALITY OF T THEMIC ANTE
T LENSKYY AND PRESIDENT BIDEN E.
HE DOESN'T FEEL HAPPY ABOUT THIS
AND ISOS
E AT IS  THE CITY D.C., "THE
WAGTT,"  RANGING
INTERVIEW THEY CAL
SOS CHOOSING VERY CAREFULLY
LANDS ONARINKEN DID CALL THE
FOREIGN MINISTER IAPRIL TO LEAK
CLEARLY SEEMS TO HAVE FALLEN WH.
YE AKS CONTAIN HIGHLY CLASSIFI
IGENCE ASSESSMENTSF
UK
WHNGTH, E
THERE WAS WE.
D K.ESNICK, ASNE PREPARING T MA.
WHEARING?
>> YEAH, OFFICIALS IK TO HATHAT
S RTAIN AMOU ME
AMMUNITION THAT THEY WOULD LTHI
NEED MORE MOME. S  TO YOU OF UR
AMON UNTIL NOW ANDREING TOAR
THH D MOVE
'RG TO
EPER IRUS
TO HIT AMMUNITN
SU, HIT THEIR SUPPLY
CHAINS AND KEEP THEM OTH
SO A CHIEF HAS SAID
RA% OF MHARDWAREE FIGHTING VTHA
NOY HAS BEEN WEAT BEEN REALLY TE
GROUND IS VERY WET, AND 'S
SAYING THAT THE COIO
YET ROBERTSON ON THE ,  NOW CNR
COURT ALLIED COMMANDER
TAYLOR.
N ADMINISTRATION ELE "THE WASHI
NING UKRAINE AT
LEAST A HEADS HE
SENSITIVE
SECRETARY OF STATE BLIEN
CALL HNTERPART THAT N MINISTER U
EMBARRASSING.
DENIE'SBARRASSING LEAK.
BU THINGISRTANCE OWH JUS
SAID, IT IS THIS CER
E THERTHINK THIS DEMONSTRATES
ANY LACK OF TRUST.
I THINK THIS WAS A CLEAR
MIT HEAND NEED TO FIX
FORWARD.
W WATCHR GENERAK RIDE TOLMEN TT
THAT'S TRU TELRETARY
A LARGE
NUMBER OF PHONE CALL, CONDUCTED
A LARGE NTF  TO  ANDARTNER
THE WORLD TOCUSSR W
SERIOUSLWEG THIS
ISSUE TO INCLUDE SEVERALCO
COUNTEAR>> SO JEP H
TOR ALL OF T IF STRENGTHENING T
PRESIDEN
I THINK ITASRESIDENT
WILL HELP. YOU HAVE TO HOUSEDID
ALLIES, AND TH TEN
IT'S CIN.RE
WHAT TNIATES I GIVE.TO ME TH
THE LEAK IS  ILETHAT ITHING
IN THE. EMS NOTWORTHY.
SO IU'KRD
YOU'REY RM
KEEPING THE COUNTER OFFENSIVE
ETLAST
THING YOU WANT IY
TECE SYSTEM IN THE
DO T GETS THECONCEALED INFORMA,
FROM THE RNTF US IT'CUMBENON
WHITUS R
RE
T MEAN, GENERAK?MEAN AS UKRAINE
MILI CSIVEUMABLY ITH DAYON THINS
TO PUB
E
SAYING IT FOR A YEAR.T A LOT O
-S SELF THATHH, MOO
LET'S MOVE OUR FREADY FOR IT
THAT'S NOT THEIT IT INDICATES W
ANS ANE TALKINABIVE ISSUES AND E
IMMEDIATE REINFORCEMENT F REE K